형식적인 수준에서,
사용하는 계산 모델에 따라 기본 연산을 정의하는
다양한 방법이 있어요.
예를 들어, 튜링 머신 모델을 사용한다면 기본 연산은 튜링 머신의 한 단계가 될 수 있어요.
이 강의에서는 이미 말했듯이 circuit 모델에 초점을 맞출 거예요. 구체적으로 quantum
circuit과 Boolean circuit이요.
circuit으로 작업할 때는, 각 gate를 기본 연산으로 생각하는 게 일반적이에요.
시리즈에서 지금까지 여러 가지 quantum gate를 봤는데,
X, Y, Z gate, Hadamard gate, S와 T gate,
controlled NOT gate, swap gate, Toffoli gate, 그리고 Fredkin gate를 포함해서요.
질의 모델의 맥락에서 query gate에 대해서도 이야기했지만, 이 강의에서는 질의 모델 안에서 작업하지 않을 거니까
지금은 query gate에 대해 걱정하지 않을게요.
또한 임의의 수의 qubit에 대한 모든 유니터리 연산을
원하면 gate로 볼 수 있다는 것도 봤어요.
하지만 비용을 측정하는 목적으로는 그건 별로 도움이 안 되니까, gate의 집합을 선택하고
그 집합을 기본 연산의 집합으로 볼 거예요.
먼저, 여기 보이는
단일 qubit 유니터리 gate를 포함할 거예요.
X, Y, Z gate,
Hadamard gate, S와 T gate, 그리고 그것들의 역행렬
또는 켤레 전치를 포함해서요.
이 gate들이 전부 필요한 건 아니에요. Hadamard와 T gate만 있으면 나머지를 구현할 수 있어요.
하지만 편의를 위해 전부 포함할 거예요.
controlled NOT gate도 포함할 건데, 이것들이 우리 집합에서
유일한 다중 qubit gate가 될 거예요.
마지막으로 단일 qubit 표준 기저 측정을 포함해서
circuit에서 실제로 고전 정보를 얻을 수 있게 할 거예요.
유니터리 gate에만 초점을 맞추고 측정을
잠시 잊으면, 이른바 보편적 gate 집합을 얻게 돼요.
그게 의미하는 건 임의의 수의 qubit에 대한
모든 유니터리 연산을 정확히 구현하거나
이 gate들만으로 만든
quantum circuit으로 임의로 가깝게 구현할 수 있다는 거예요.
다시 말해, 이것들로 모든 유니터리
연산을 만들 수 있는 충분한 gate 집합이에요.
반드시 정확하게는 아니지만, 원하는 만큼
좋은 근사를 얻을 수 있어요.
많은 gate가 필요할 수 있고, 때때로 많은 gate가
필요할 수밖에 없다는 걸 추론하는 건 사실 어렵지 않아요.
하지만 그럼에도 불구하고 항상 가능해요.
이것이 보편적 gate 집합이라는 걸 증명하는 건 간단한 문제가 아닌데요.
시리즈에서 어떻게 하는지는 다루지 않을 거예요.
하지만 이건 꽤 잘 알려진 사실이고 증명할 수 있는
다양한 방법이 있어요.
이것 대신 때때로 사용되는 다른 gate 집합도 있어요.
Toffoli gate, Hadamard gate, S gate에 측정을 더한 것 같은 거요.
하지만 이건 꽤 표준적인 선택이에요.
그래서 요약하면, 이것들이 우리가
기본적이라고 볼 양자 연산이에요.
Boolean circuit에서는
이 네 가지 gate를 기본 연산으로 간주할 거예요: AND gate, OR gate, NOT gate, 그리고 FANOUT이요.
참고로 FANOUT은 항상
gate로 간주되지는 않지만, 강의 후반에서 보겠지만
이걸 gate로 세는 게 중요할 거예요.
표준 quantum gate 집합과 비슷하게,
이 집합도 약간 중복돼요.
AND와 OR 둘 다 필요하지 않아요. NOT gate 세 개와 함께 다른 하나를 사용해서 어느 쪽이든 만들 수 있어요.
하지만 둘 다 포함해도 문제없고 그냥 편리해요.
이미 아실 수 있듯이, 이건 결정론적 계산을 위한
보편적 gate 집합이에요. 비트에서 비트로의 모든 함수를
이 컬렉션의 gate로 구성된 Boolean circuit으로 구현할 수 있다는 뜻이에요.
다시 한번, quantum circuit에서와
마찬가지로, 모든 함수가 Boolean circuit으로 효율적으로 구현될 수 있다는 뜻은 아니에요.
실제로 대부분의 함수는 매우 큰 circuit으로만
구현할 수 있어요. 단순히 함수가 매우 많고
작은 circuit으로 전부 커버할 수 없기 때문이에요.
작은 circuit이 충분하지 않아요.
보편성은 양자의 경우보다
이 경우에 증명하기가 더 쉬워요.
그래서 증명하는 방법을 아직 모르신다면,
관심이 있으시다면 한번 생각해 보고 알아낼 수 있는지 해보세요.
이제 허용하고 기본 연산으로 간주할
gate를 정했으니, 그것들이 얼마나 많이
다양한 계산을 수행하는 데
필요한지 생각할 수 있어요.
그러기 위해 circuit의
크기에 대한 이 정의를 사용할 거예요.
이 정의는 Boolean과 quantum
circuit 모두에 작동하고 아주 간단해요.
circuit의 크기는
총 gate 수예요.
예를 들어, 우리가 여러 번 본
같은 예시로 돌아가면, 두 비트의 배타적 OR를 계산하는 Boolean circuit이에요.
크기가 7인 걸 볼 수 있어요.
FANOUT gate 2개, NOT gate 2개,
AND gate 2개, OR gate 1개, 총 7개의 gate가 있으니까요. FANOUT gate를 세지 않기로 하면
(이게 일반적인데) 크기는 5가 되겠지만,
우리는 FANOUT gate를 셀 거니까 크기는 7이에요.